أكره أن أخيب آمال كل الرافضين
ونيوم هو حقيقة الخط حقيقة إنه
مشروع تحويلي إنه
شيء لم يراه العالم سيؤدي إلى
التطرف ويحدث ثورة أه
الطريقة التي ينظر بها الناس إلى المدن وينظرون إلى
التخطيط الحضري هو كذلك  التفكير خارج
الصندوق الذي لم تتم تجربته
من قبل وهو قيد التنفيذ بينما نتحدث أم
أنه من المفترض أن يكون بحجم
مدينة نيويورك حيث سيعيش حوالي 9 ملايين شخص
هناك ،
هل هذا قابل للحياة اقتصاديًا
بالطبع ، وإلا فلن نتمكن من ذلك.
نتعهد به ولا يُعرف أننا
أشخاص ساذجون ، فنحن معروفون بكوننا
أشخاصًا مدروسين للغاية وأشخاصًا يعتقدون على
المدى الطويل أن هذا مشروع طويل الأجل جدًا ، إنه
مشروع طموح للغاية
وهو مشروع
غير تحويلي.  فقط للمملكة العربية
السعودية ولكني أعتقد أنه بالنسبة للحياة الحضرية بشكل
عام ، فهذه محاولة لإنشاء
مدينة صديقة للبيئة
تكون مستدامة وتتمتع
بمستوى عالٍ جدًا من جودة الحياة التي
لا يوجد بها حركة مرور تقريبًا ، يمكنك الذهاب إلى
أماكن مختلفة بكفاءة عالية
بدون  باستخدام السيارات ، لا توجد سيارات ولا
سيارة واحدة ، ستكون
أنواعًا مختلفة من وسائل النقل
كما قلت صديقة للبيئة ،
وستكون الطاقة المتجددة قائمة على أساسها